Boris Johnson is fighting for his
political life today as he faces MPS for
intensive questioning that could decide
his future during the last hour the
privilege committee has published new
material as part of the inquiry into
Downing Street parties during covid
lockdowns the former prime minister has
admitted misleading the House of Commons
over the party's but insists it wasn't
intentional well our political
correspondent Tamara Cohen joins me now
so tomorrow take us through what's been
published in the last hour
morning Ian so a 110 page bundle of
documents has been published by the
Privileges committee and this is going
to be the framework for this bombshell
appearance by Boris Johnson at the
committee this afternoon this afternoon
and both sides legal teams are going to
rely on a wealth of messages and govid
guidance contained in them let me show
you a few bits that we've seen in there
today so one of the key questions is
going to relate to whether Boris Johnson
should have just noticed that these
gatherings were not within the rules and
in particular there was a garden party
held in number 10 in May of 2020 that he
attended for a bit he wasn't fined over
it and we've been reminded of the email
from his private secretary Martin
Reynolds who said after an incredibly
busy period we thought it'd be nice to
make the most of this lovely weather and
have some socially distanced drinks now
we see some evidence from Dominic
Cummings about that party he says the
idea the Prime Minister could have
thought this drinks event was work is
comical given the tables were covered in
bottles of drink everyone was standing
around and the Prime Minister certainly
knew it was a drinks party because I
told him it was and when he walked out
he saw a drinks party so Boris Johnson
will be questioned about whether he was
recklessly or deliberately misleading
Parliament when he said there were no
gatherings
and that's that evidence from Dominic
Cummings there's also a very interesting
piece of evidence from the person who
organized that drinks party Martin
Reynolds he was a Boris Johnson's
private secretary when it came to
December of the following year when they
were the story had emerged in the mirror
and they were having to justify it at
Prime Minister's questions this is what
Martin Reynolds said was their
conversation at the time he says I do
recall asking the Prime Minister about
the line proposed for prime minister's
questions on the 7th of December
suggesting all rules and guidance had
been followed I can't remember exactly
when I did this would have been the
period roughly an hour before it started
he said he didn't welcome the
interruption but told me he'd received
assurances the comms event was within
the rules I accepted this but questioned
whether it was realistic to argue all
guidance had been followed given the
nature of the working environment in
number 10 and he agreed to delete the
reference to the guidance so this is
really important because at that prime
minister's questions when Boris Johnson
is now on trial for misleading MPS he
actually did say that all rules and
guidance had been followed he didn't
follow Martin reynolds's advice and the
MPS will be questioning whether he had
been warned that the guidance was not
followed and went ahead and said it
anyway now Boris Johnson's team feel
that some of this evidence is actually
quite helpful to them they're relying a
lot on messages he exchanged with his
communications director Jack Doyle who
Boris Johnson says assured him no rules
are broken I'll just show you a bit of
this uh this these conversations that he
and Jack Doyle had and when the stories
started to emerge about it
this is what Jack Doyle said to the to
the initial inquiry into the parties you
know did you give him assurances and
Jack Dawes says yes in discussion with
colleagues in a broader discussion I
said to the Prime Minister I didn't
regard this as a party uh these are this
is regarding gatherings in November and
December and we didn't believe the rules
had been broken that's what we said at
Lobby the rules is a judgment for others
it was not an organized party the
interviewer then says to say this in
Parliament is a big thing for the Prime
Minister and Jack Doyle says he had
conversations with others as well but he
I said we are saying this wasn't a party
and no rules were broken so that is what
Boris Johnson's defense is going to
hinge on the test for the committee is
whether he either intentionally misled
MPS Boris Johnson admits that he misled
MPS whether he intentionally did so or
whether he did so recklessly I.E he
should have simply known when he
attended these gatherings which at one
point in his evidence he actually refers
to as a party saying it was a kind of
shorthand he was using whether he should
have just walked into a room like the
one you're seeing there and just known
that he was doing the wrong thing Boris
Johnson's political career hinges on
whether the committee believed his
defense